Reidy
damn I forgot what all that just said
stormtroopers with infamous bad aims
somehow managed to actually kill anna
frebel soldiers here to take over the
ship they survived this Darth Vader
could choke fools just by using the hand
gesture we learned that later on in this
very movie so why is it getting all
touch me in the morning with this rebel
scum man Vader's got to get back close
to a guy who's committed his life to
overthrowing the government you get that
close homing grab Vader's lightsaber to
kill the Sith out of mr. suddenly
touchy-feely yell Vader choke that
chicken from across the road bro and you
didn't seem to have a problem firing on
the ship or having your stormtroopers
blasting away when they torched the door
down Leia's plan is to shoot once at
four stormtroopers then Prometheus cool
of running away from things into the
open hallway that offers no cover I'm
not getting in didn't Vader tell these
fools he wanted passengers alive hey
it's a good thing that the Star
Destroyer didn't completely swallow the
smaller ship or else this escape pod
would have crashed into the floor
somewhere hold your fire
there's no life-forms unless this is the
first day that droids were released to
an unsuspecting buying public everyone
in the galaxy knows about droids and
their capabilities but they just let the
escape pod go because of no life-forms
they don't even want to shoot the thing
down just to be safe man these guys are
the biggest fuck-ups in all the Star
Wars movies and that's a short-circuited
oh oh right you're right that's stupid
assumption it's the most likely reason
for an escape pod to jettison from a
recently captured rebel ship under siege
escape pod was jettisoned during the
fighting no life-forms were aboard you
mean an escape pod like one escape pod
why did the other guys say there goes
another one which implies more than one
Royds are moving so slowly that there's
no way they shouldn't be caught
immediately by Vader's troopers oh well
that's convenient I spent the whole
afternoon going in opposite directions
and still got to the same place
well Jabba's cover some damn ground man
also do they have this main sandcrawler
ship going around while they dumped off
loads of Java's to hide in the mountains
in case lost robots show up I guess
you're right George
this scene felt so incomplete without
the CGI writing wizard in the background
also isn't it lucky that these things
have claws that don't leave any tracks
that makes their appearance more
cost-effective and unrealistic that
conveniently dropped pieces of
themselves along the way like brick gums
room at roll call I suppose you're
programmed for etiquette and protocol
uncle Owen rejects droids immediately
with a simple note and knows exactly
what c-3po does just by looking at but
mysteriously talks to him anyway
I'm guessing so c-3po can persuade uncle
Owen
I was going into tosche station to pick
up some power converters all right every
right-thinking human being on the planet
is gonna sin this awkward line and it's
equally cinebulle reading in Heaven's we
were looking for some daemon here and we
got some affleck instead this power
converted thing sounds like a lie to me
man like when my friend Malcolm would
say I'm going a CityWalk guy and then
they secretly hook up with dudes at bear
bars so I'm saying Luke wanted to go to
Tashi but it wasn't his power he wanted
converted he was sneaking away for
public restroom rendezvoused with
Arcturians man male or female don't
matter was Arcturian baby red droid
melts down conveniently so that r2 can
get a job and stay with his buddy hey
what are you trying to push on us hey
yeah I mean I thought you were reputable
salesman with your Sanger lore full of
random robot selections you mean the one
you instantly dismissed earlier Luke is
a teenager who plays with model t16
skyhopper probably so you knew what to
buy when you went to the toy store I'm
not even sure which well if there's a
bright Center to the universe you're on
the planet that is farthest from he's a
droid it's not your dude bro it doesn't
understand sarcasm man homie may be
fluent in over six million forms of
communication but wise ass ain't one of
them stop confusing your sex droids wait
they're not sex troy'd the one shaped
like a human and little mister
ride-height they're not sex droids man
that's a sin right there who's she she's
beautiful how can you tell it's a blue
hologram full of 1970s also if he could
discern whether she's beautiful or not
why can't he figure out that this is
Princess Leia you know about the Civil
War going on and she has the title of
Princess so how is she unfamiliar to you
called obi-wan Kenobi phony might have
meant old Dan say both these guys named
Kenobi you think they know each other
homie changes the Obi one part of his
name it keeps the easily identifying
Kenobi last name if he'd gone with Ben
Jonson literally none of the rest of
this movie could ever happen man and
don't tell me it's because Kenobi knew
one day or one day Luke would need to
find a man he's in hiding like all the
Jedi that are left alive just admit it
man dude's got a good heart but he chose
a stupid stupid alias he has too much of
his father in him
that's what I'm afraid understatement
foreshadow is that under shadowing how
is it this dark out with Toussaint's you
think the combined power would make it
look like daytime out here also sons
this close together it would cause
wicked and sanity on this planet one son
would heat the other son dogs and cats
living together mass hysteria
[Music]
the director said ok Luke just stare at
the Suns because any line you might say
would honestly make this scene worse
it's too dangerous with all the
sandpeople that's racist dead ahead
thank God we went in the one direction
r2 did so we could find him Hindi celery
driving this thing you are c-3po he's
probably saying hold your fire
there's no life-forms obvious reverse
job is obvious but instead of killing
Luke he just knocks him out for some
reason how did he knock him out it can't
be with the weapon he's holding that's
sure death if you get hit by that thing
now that's the name I've not know Oh
obi-wan basically half truth is when you
through this entire movie I was once a
Jedi Knight now this is the first time
Luke's even hearing about his Jedi dad
but the real news here is that his uncle
has been lying his ass off for years man
forget the dad you never knew stuff this
uncle Owen this farmer who's trying to
pull moisture out of the deserts like a
dick he's the liar you always thought he
was man your whole life is a lie get
your revenge Luke you go back and you
burn your lion uncle alive right in
front of his own hat look too late
[Music]
damn obi-wan you might have wanted to
tell Luke which way to point that thing
before turning it on which is what I
tell all my six droids Luke could have
accidentally cut off the head of old man
exposition movie franchise nearly sends
obi-wan to his death 75 minutes too
early ending said movie franchise again
the force the force is what gives a Jedi
his power it's an energy field created
by all living things and something about
midi-chlorians but that's not nearly
schools what I'm saying it surrounds us
penetrates is a force kind of sounds
like a sex offender years ago you served
my father in the Clone Wars
any time you want to tell Luke but this
is his long-lost sister here's your
chance obi-wan don't try to frighten us
with your sorcerers ways lord Vader
oh look at mister keeping it real man
this has to be his first
day on the job am i right as Darth Vader
never shown his powers at any time
during this guy's life I imagine that
right before he left for work his wife
was telling him you got to be more
assertive in that job if you want to get
ahead honey don't be afraid to speak
your mind to your bosses they like
people who challenge them slow-ass
stormtroopers only recently killed these
Jabba fools they left the Star Destroyer
one minute after the droids but are
somehow a day and a half behind it looks
like the sandpeople did this all right
I've never heard of them eating anything
this big beautiful they didn't but we
are meant to think they did because
Imperial Stormtroopers know what about
Tatooine and San people in order to
frame their ass and these last points
too accurate for sandpeople only
Imperial Stormtroopers are so precise
[Laughter]
look I know we got to get Luke into
space somehow but the stormtroopers just
gone melt as aunt and uncle and don't
think I don't know maybe we should ask
some questions maybe we should figure
out if this boy is coming home super
maybe with the droids we're looking for
but they don't man they just leave they
just create destruction just leave you
know it would have been more metal than
this if they ripped the flesh from these
dirt farmers bones and dressed up in
their skins can you imagine that Luke
comes home and he's greeted by
stormtroopers wearing the bloody skins
of Aunt Beru and uncle Owen draped over
their helmets and they're asking about
droids like I would tell them anything
man I'd even tell them what I was really
doing whenever I went to tashi station
oh I see the Death Star has branded
their truth serum robot so that all
visitors know this isn't some knockoff
Death Star here also how was Leia able
to deny the truth serums effects don't
tell me she's a Jedi we don't know that
yet
and she doesn't know that yet and if she
Jedi her way out of this somehow Vader
would have sensed it obi-wan said okay
c-3po let's burn a giant pile of Java
bodies because that's the absolute last
of their race and no one will ever miss
them burials are for closers only I want
to come with you to Alderaan even though
I have tons of other options at this
point also Luke doesn't seem all that
broken up about his aunt and uncle dying
does he he must have had a titanic cry
on the way to the giant Massacre site
you will never find
more wretched hive of scum and villainy
except Gary Indiana of course you've got
some obvious Phantom Menace in my new
hope that's racist this iconic tavern
scene does not contain an alien lap
dance among the many creatures here
Satan also likes to hang out in the
cantina that's bassist we don't serve
their kind
Threepio gets a taste of his own rhesus
Medicine 90 seconds after dismissing the
Jawas I don't like the look at this all
the unnecessarily added CGI Baloo
me neither like every other citizen of
the first world with enough time on
their hands to care about this kind of
we're all so mad that Han no longer
shoots Greedo first like the
cold-blooded badass he was in the 1977
cut of the movie so we're gonna send
this but did you have to make grito such
a horrible shot this might be the worst
shot in the history of movies man he's
literally three feet away and he misses
like a dick dude's supposed to be a
bounty hunter
this is his first day on the job like
the mouthy guy in the Death Star is Star
Wars really a movie about a bunch of
people starting their first day at a new
job Han is addictive Jabba's tail and
these special effects are addictive the
audience what Luke is the most annoying
backseat driver since your mom commence
primary ignition it takes 10 seconds for
the Death Star to shoot its laser after
this remember that kids when this takes
forever later this yellow monster dies
immediately from getting lifted what a
pussy you need to control your actions
harshly but it also obeys your commands
oh wait what your eyes can deceive you
don't trust them yeah but I'm gonna
guess your eyes don't deceive you as
much as everything else you use to
detect things it's not like the Jedi is
going around blind holding each other
before a lightsaber match this asshole
Luke isn't feeling the force already
after spending just a couple hours with
that floaty ball I call it life in my
experience there's no such thing as luck
you just experience luck it's okay to
give it and accept it let the hate flow
through you I told you she would never
consciously betray the rebellion and to
emphasize this point I'm going to start
gesturing after I talk terminate her
immediately immediately on the Death
Star means being around for a couple of
hours waiting for the Millennium Falcon
to arrive and save the day did they get
out of hyperspace just before chunks of
Alderaan slammed into their ship because
experience that's some serious luck
right there also lucky is that the death
star just happens to be around Alderaan
right now
that way you can say Princess Leia and
this trip will be meaningless well he
ain't gonna be around long enough to
tell anybody about us why is it taking
so long to get in range to blast this
one little Thai fighter this ship made
the Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs
we must be trying to return the stolen
plans to the princess she may yet be of
some use to us you can't possibly think
that don't get the idea to rescue Leia
from her prison or that don't even find
out she's here remember it takes a
crazy-ass plan to get into the control
room and r2 messing around with the
computer to even find out that
information even if you have an idea to
capture them put them in Leia so and
hope she blabs to them about where the
secret base is this is silly Leia bullsh
you and proved too strong for the mind
probe so she's officially useless Darth
Vader needs to start setting up charges
on the Millennium Falcon take the Death
Star plans back destroy Luke and execute
Leia at the same time while his children
get baptized in the Catholic Church
Godfather style wait there's no one on
board sir let me get this straight you
have sensors that could tell whether
there are life forms on an escape pod
but you can't detect life-forms on a
ship inside the Death Star
knowing this anybody could send a ship
full of killer droids buried in the
floorboards to kill and take out the
entire Empire and people bitch about our
TSA persons have not filled seats since
when since when they've already reported
to Vader that no one is here so these
stormtroopers were sent on the ship -
basically what walk-around and confirm
what the last crew of stormtroopers just
did a second ago the stormtroopers are
still on the ramp exiting the ship and
Han picks this exact moment to open the
secret panel on the floor and also my
guess he figures there's no way they're
coming back or that it could be a trip
even for smuggling yeah bone smugglin
stage I apologize if that joke fell for
some stage again but here's the thing
your big conflict with Jabba was that
you had to let go cargo when you got
boarded man but you have all these
secret panels in the floor that the
Empire can't find so why do you ever
sweat getting boarded sounds like a
rookie move like maybe it was your first
day on the job or something like that
this movie is just like the office in
outer space man Han is Jim Luke is
Dwight and Greedo is like Ryan the temp
and why did Obi one get his own
compartment while Luke and Han had to go
three-way with the Wookiee that beats my
fanfiction but why oh so this is the
scanning team why didn't some of the
stormtrooper stay on board into the
team was ready to go scanning the ship
requires loading this huge cumbersome
box on the ship itself I know this is
set a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away but you have technology that beats
us here in 2015 and I know that simple
heat signature technology would tell us
there are assholes on this ship blaster
fire inside heavily guarded ship raises
no alarm or suspicion it sure is lucky
that hana luke blasted the two
stormtroopers with the exact same size
uniforms they needed and those suits are
remarkably intact after getting blasted
a second ago you know between his
howling and your blasting everything in
sight of one of the whole station
doesn't know we're here
Luke Skywalker two would be excellent at
cinemasins phallic data extraction also
thankfully the Death Star has a computer
port that has access to the entire
station that also happens to match r2d2
s output thingy I'm afraid I'm not quite
sure sir he says I found her and keeps
repeating she's here
c-3po defines the problem with the
pronoun game while r2d2 plays it
oh-hoo-hoo is he found Princess Leia you
just said you didn't know who he was
talking about an r2d2 has not said
anything since the conversation started
well more wealth than you can imagine
Luke is drawn by the power of boners to
take on the whole goddamn Death Star and
Han is drawn by the power of money
boners there is no way the Empire
created something so innocent and jovial
Swamper brain is only good while good
guys occupy the costumes although it
still kind of takes them along to
conversation anyway I'm surprised this
radio didn't shoot on first Han and
Chewie somehow need to retreat while
holding this super tiny opening in the
elevator these troopers a car then the
entire rest of the scene
none of the Imperial troopers come down
this hall and fire into this obvious
escape hole into the garbage compactor
everyone survives this bullshit but when
did you ever have time to try shooting
the door before Han jumped down to shoot
man he jumped down four seconds after
you did and held Chewbacca was standing
there at the door when Han landed it's
your life Luke Skywalker I call you fib
Fortuna as a deep cuts reference man
achievements unlocks there's something
alive in here the Empire just recently
threw a live swimming creature into this
garbage disposal just before our heroes
jumped down in it because how else would
it have survived the numerous amounts of
compacting unless it's Gumby or
something
how does Luke get swallowed whole by the
shallow-water this creature isn't okay
at this point luke is dead
that dude drown he comes from a desert
planet with virtually no water and no
practice with water he's out of his
element
the Empire's addicted tall stormtroopers
if you hurry you might catch them
these still aren't the droids we're
looking for yeah what thank God for
extremely slow trash compactors ah han
shoots one guy and the entire
stormtrooper unit starts running away
and it's not like they're setting a
logical trap because the ship is in a
different direction will Storm Trooper
strike me down I shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
basically I'll be able to occasionally
talk to Luke through ghost power so
there honestly this is pretty badass and
it makes sense for the plot - obi-wan
knows he's outmatched he knows Luke
would stick around to try and save him
and we'd never get on the ship and so we
will remove five sins for Obi Wan's
badassery right here no here's a blanket
Luke wouldn't want you to catch cold or
some we did it for the record Princess
Leia is a badass but in this scene she
didn't do anything you're sure the
homing beacon is secure aboard their
ship this might explain why the
stormtroopers were so awful at shooting
our heroes earlier but how did they
coordinate this plan with everyone on
the Death Star
was it make the shooting look good but
don't hit them you might die but it's
for the greater good or did Vader set it
up so the heroes could escape but didn't
mind if they got killed in the process
they're tracking us not this ship sister
well your male confidence certainly is
convincing I guess we should just go
straight to the rebel base without any
precautions an analysis of the plans
provided by Princess Leia Princess Leia
hear all your stories when we get back
alright
it'd be like old times Luke he'll never
stop us this guy is trying to drink's
the entire mission and he's definitely
dead for some reason the Death Star
doesn't use its tractor beam to render
these ships useless Hopey one turned it
off but he didn't destroy it I'm going
in cover me Porkins what have I told you
about calling me Porkins
analyze their attack sir and there is a
danger should I have your ship standing
by or maybe get some of our ships in
formation over the one weakness this
entire space station has so that a
direct hit doesn't destroy us Vader
launch on its target then immediately
sprays fire over everything except it's
targeted for the first two seconds of
firing
just like old times man they'll never
stop you use the Vosloo
your targeting computer is a piece of
dogs Luke okay guys this took ten
seconds with Alderaan so it's gonna take
about as long o ly and it takes 48
seconds for this thing to even get close
to firing man so the first time they use
it the Death Star unleashes a massive
payload all over the face neck and chest
of Alderaan
that money shots it out of existence but
it takes way longer if it wants to go
again this is the most erotic Lee
charged line in the movie and something
I say to Jason Mewes whenever we go to
city wok if you follow me how can you
not get the chills I'll take another
five off for Luke's hit here because the
execution of this scene is awesome
hey man in the excitement I'd call her
Carrie - on some night she might be
Darlene you know no role playing can be
a powerful tool oh my god that's his
sister isn't it how come Chewbacca
doesn't get a medal man he was in the
Falcon - he helped take out Vader and
save Luke's ass and look even yells
about it at this point he goes like
roars my medal and everyone just
collapsed like yay the status quo is
maintained on this little animal farm
we're all animals are equal but some
animals are more equal than others
this is horse it's always bothered me
about this move man let the wookie win a
medal this is it really winning since he
so clearly deserves it i'ma leave it at
that
that's dying auntie curse magnetic poppy
I wasn't fast enough it's all my friend
three weeks after we started cinemasins
Kevin Smith tweeted about us once we
were revived by medical personnel we
noticed a super obvious Kevin Smith has
tweeted about you rise and our
subscribers and statistics this man put
us on the map I gave you back I gave you
back the math we figured the best way to
thank him was to ask him to guess nary
the sins of maybe the biggest geek movie
we could ever sit we'd also thought
you'd like to know he has a youtube
channel which will link in the
description below where you can check
out videos of fat man on Batman
Hollywood babble-on
and more please go show him some love
thanks Kevin ever since cinemasins began
the most requested thing has been TV
since and now it's a reality click the
link in the description below to check
it out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
space a final frontier r2d2 where are
you where are you we got some work to do
now
[Music]
sorry as a peeping everyday that man
remains free is one more failure 347
days gentlemen 347 failures terminate
her immediately
now tomorrow not after breakfast now
[Music]
you